[Music]
hey
happy sunday everybody hopefully
everybody can hear me
yep i keep checking this [ __ ] audio
and
you know seems like it's okay most of
the time but then sometimes it's like
hey nope
yeah so we're doing uh fire and ice i
think that was uh 1983 or
that's 82 it was um we got sent this by
a patron
esther this is and um got it on blu-ray
now
i had never seen this movie i'd seen
little clips of it it looked cool
um it looked like something out of a
rosetta painting
so she sent it to us and i watched it
and it's a tight little flick it's good
um it's all rotoscope which was it was
shot on film and then they did
illustrations over it um they're
inspired by
frank fazetta he did a lot of work for
this uh uh for this
and but a lot of other people drew it
did all the drawings
all this was hand drawn this is before
computers uh well you know computer
computer animation so this
this movie is a work of art man it's
really good um
it's the idea was to bring like a frank
rosetta painting to life
and i think it pretty much does that
it's kind of a world kind of like a
conan
uh it doesn't have the conan label on it
uh it's more like something out of
like one of those little british films
like you know people at time forgot it's
kind of like that
cavemen cave women barbarians
troglodytes little sub humans yeah boobs
and um dinosaurs and uh
wizards you know sorcerers and uh
with kind of like this uh apocalyptic
theme you know between the
power of ice and the power of fire
pretty cool actually um
jenny says they had boobs it did they
look like the women the
the women look like something out of a
frizzetta painting because they were
technically
yeah i mean he did not he did the
character design you did the character
this time yeah what was funny is that
they went back and or you know and and
this this dvd had a bunch
of this blu-ray had a bunch of extra
features and they showed who was
actually playing these roles
and they uh talked to the director and
everything and they went through like
thousands of young starlets
to try to find the best ones who looked
like these rosetta
paintings and could do it but when you
actually saw who they were they only
looked like the animated verses in the
face they they really voluptuoized them
a lot
but it wasn't like outside human realm
really you know what i mean that you
would think that out of a thousand girls
you could probably get one with that
figure
yeah i guess you could they never did
really explain why but that but then
you'd need somebody that could
was like a stunt person yeah because it
was they were very physical roles yeah
they were
you know doing a lot of stunts yeah and
a lot of them did their own [ __ ] i think
yeah like out of the conan movie the
woman who played valeria
she was a she was a dancer a dancer and
she really did have that physique that's
why she got that role but she could act
too
yeah you can train a person to act it
doesn't really take that long as long as
they're not
as long as they have some talent you can
bring it out of them
i mean it'd probably be easier to teach
somebody to act than to teach them to do
all those stuff
dance and things like that because
that's much harder you know what i mean
but uh yeah so this movie like we said
it came out in 1983
we got heavy metal too but i don't think
we've done a review of that or we've
talked about it
kind of on other things but i don't
think we've done a dedicated one
i don't think so we should probably we
should probably do that one of these
days yeah um
and the weird thing about it so we were
watching this last night i could have
sworn
that i had seen this movie already um
but then we were watching it i was like
you know what i don't think i did see it
i think i was thinking about ralph
bakshi's
other movie wizards that came out in
1977
because remember i think we watched that
one either we watched that one
or i saw i don't know i must have seen
it at some point
and i know i've seen like a couple of
reviews of it because i think [ __ ]
cinema did it and i think
um brandon tennold might have done it so
but i know i'm familiar with that one so
i was getting it confused with fire and
ice i guess
even though there's like some crossover
like i said it's still ralph bakshi he's
the same guy that uh directed it and
it's still like sword and sorcery and
there's even kind of some
uh overlap with character names because
like the bad guy in fire and ice is
named necron
and i think there was a character like a
robot or something like that that was in
wizards that was also named
necron or necron 99 or something like
that
so i think there was like some carry
over with names and i think one of the
wizard in wizards
one or the bad wizard i think was named
black wolf black skull something like
that
can we talk about in this movie no no in
wizards and then in this one
uh the the hero of the movie who doesn't
seem like the hero at first but then
like later he comes in you're like oh
this guy's the hero
he's uh he's named what dark wolf right
yeah dark wolf
something like that even though they
said his original name i think was death
dealer which i was like oh i like that
better well that was the name of a
painting that the yeah i know
that rosetta did if you don't know who
rosetta is frisetta
painted that right back there and that's
some people said that's a poster that's
not a poster that's
that's a print on on a uh on campus on
canvas itself
and all that his stuff was real heroic
real
big dudes [ __ ] into kind of primal
stuff
even if it was a world war ii painting
uh he had the guys
kind of [ __ ] real heroic figures the
women were real voluptuous really kind
of like
the body style that i like a lot of guys
like that
and um he was a great artist i mean when
he was working on this
all the other artists they didn't tell
frank but all the other artists [ __ ]
worshiped him so much they were so
nervous around him that they froze up
they couldn't really yeah they were like
scared to draw anything because they
were like they thought it wouldn't be
good enough
and frank was a what was kind of like an
outstanding guy real unusual for an
artist i mean
usually artists are aspiring to some
kind of beauty you know what i mean and
they'll paint these beautiful paintings
of people and women and dudes
but you looked at them they weren't much
to look at you know what i mean
looking a lot of times that kind of like
they were overcompensating maybe because
they lacked
physical beauty in some ways not frank
all right
let me show you what frank looked like
all right
what happened i'm looking for that
painting a picture
this is what frank looked like okay
okay frank looked like the guys that he
drew
especially when he was young and he
would like
take photos of himself you know what i
mean and kind of like these heroic
poses with guns and
he was a real kind of a macho dude so he
just gravitated towards that
he was like a good-looking greaser guy
and um so it wasn't one of the kind of
situations where you know
nowadays you might have some oh nobody
looks like that or that sexist
[ __ ] dress and
drawing those women like that no he
looked like that too
and he had girlfriends and wives that
looked like that he was you know that's
the way he was
and i kind of admired that in him
that not only would did he know how to
like paint
physical beauty he tried to become that
he would work out you know yeah i like
that you know what i mean
he he he wasn't taking an easy path you
know
and um not all artists are like that
that's all i'm gonna say yeah um so the
story well so the story behind this it's
actually like a pretty simple
uh fantasy story like you said you have
uh
the evil people who live in a place
called ice peak
and there's a queen named juliana and
she has a son named necron who is also
like a sorcerer
like he is the force kind of yeah and um
so and he can control glaciers and
whatnot and then there's the other
uh you know the other citadel which is
called it's not called fire peak it's
called fire what is it called
fire something i don't know i don't
remember though there's just a bunch of
crazy names in terms of yeah
and uh really matter though yeah this
it's a simple story
really that the whole damn plot of the
story is a real
simple save the girl and save the world
type [ __ ] she gets getting kidnapped
she keeps getting kidnapped by some
humans and getting away and then getting
kidnapped again and getting away yeah
kidnapped again
some of the more interesting elements of
the story that were originally there
were taken out
which i didn't really agree with that
like turns out that like dark wolf who's
like one of the best characters in there
he's kind of like the
kind of like the primitive caveman
version of batman
and he is a batman type character um
turns out he was actually the father of
necron
but they cut that out of the movie
that's where they should have left that
in
should have left that i'm not really
entirely sure why they took that out
there was a bunch of stuff about necrons
mom that they cut out
um there's some stuff that where
it was good to have it in the movie but
it didn't really serve a big purpose
like
in one part the little princess the
little runaway princess and
she starts because she says it sucks
that i'm locked up in here
just waiting to get married away to some
you know
buffed out dude when and and all the men
are getting all the glory in the wind
and women like me just you know wait
around for these dudes to marry them you
know
well she gets her wish and ends up
getting going on a great adventure where
she gets
abducted by the trump by basically
troglodytes these primitives
that just go around yeah yeah they're
kind of like they're
like they couldn't say orcs you know
what i mean that's all
you know from tolkien's world so they're
basically orcs
they call them subhuman they call them
sub humans they got later
bangs and [ __ ] kind of criminal
primitive looking kind of like uh homo
erectus or something
like they can kind of talk because they
do talk to each other yeah not
they they just kind of grunted each
other and just yeah
yeah they saved men kind of they served
i guess the evil sorceress
made them i get was that the implication
yeah i think they were made by them
i guess they did [ __ ] that was not real
you couldn't really understand like they
don't
really have any clothes but they had no
problem living in a damn ice castle with
[ __ ] blizzards and [ __ ] walking
around in their bare feet walking around
bare feet
not getting frostbite yeah i think they
were kind of imaginative i think they
were a magically created race kind of
like the damn orcs were
sauron made them maybe and the bad guy
is kind of like a sauron type figure
although tigra the princess she runs
around in the snow and in the forest and
like that with no shoes and
a teeny teeny bikini like through the
whole thing it's not even a bikini
not yeah it's like i don't even it's it
i don't even think i call it
it's like a tiny it's a little
triangular patch
held to her by dental floss
and two little triangular patches
basically pasties
[Laughter]
which that's in that's that's you know
that's that's in
that's in the spirit of a frazzetta
painting it is that's the way
that's the way a woman's supposed to be
dressed but all i was thinking the whole
time was she's running and climbing and
going through the snow and the forest
and everything i'm like man her feet
must be killing her and it's like she's
having scratches all over and everything
like that but she's animated
yeah that's what i said i said that's
the way a woman's supposed to be dressed
and it has to fill it out just like that
and then do this draw on it can deliver
i mean he was the male version of that
so he's got the right to draw that [ __ ]
although what's interesting about this
is that so
you have uh you know necron and his mom
like from ice peak and they're the bad
guys and their [ __ ] glacier is
you know pushing into the you know the
other territory with like the fire
people
and you know the good guys and so it
seems like
necron wipes out most of the fight
the people in the you know in the fire
whatever and
the only guy that's left pretty much is
the king and
his son and the daughter and then this
one guy
whose name is what's his name lauren
tarn i don't remember [ __ ] man i can't
remember anyone's name
i think it's lauren the one that looks
like he-man
yeah oh the the main character the main
guy the blonde yeah i think it was
lauren
i think it's laura yeah and um so he
like pretends to be dead but then he
wakes up and then he stumbles across
tigra who has gotten in a completely
separate incident
has gotten kidnapped by the subhumans
and they're gonna take her back to ice
peak so she can marry necron but he's
not interested
then she keeps escaping and then she
gets recaptured so there's a whole thing
but then
like about halfway through the movie
this other dude
dark wolf shows up who is obviously the
hero of the movie
so you think like lauren is the hero the
whole time but he doesn't i mean he does
some heroic [ __ ]
but then it's almost kind of like dark
wolf shows up and he's like hey hold my
beard i'm like the real hero you know
what i mean
so yeah and he and like i said i kind of
feel like it's weird because there's a
lot of like really cool extra [ __ ]
on the blu-ray that esther sent us and
when they said that in the original uh
version of the script that dark wolf was
supposed to be necrons dad
that would have made so much more sense
like to the story because as it is now
you're not really sure like why dark
wolf is so dead set on
i'm killing this dude on killing this
dude because like he doesn't really have
any motivation
like to do that other than just being
the hero a bunch of stuff that was cut
out about his mom too they should have
left
all that in there they made the mistake
of trying to shorten it i think they
tried to shorten it and they tried to
dumb it down
i think for a younger audience i think
that's what it was
yeah they just didn't they just didn't
maybe they didn't want to see a younger
audience
where the dad kills the sun maybe they
didn't think that was appropriate or
something and
a damn psychotic mom who was trying to
make a move on the sun you know there
was like incestuous [ __ ] that she was
doing yeah the whole bunch
of checkpoints they took that off and
just make trying to get a pg rating
maybe that's what it was maybe they just
thought it was too unsavory
somebody keeps asking about who was it
that asked about it i think scott asked
about the mazinga in the background
i don't know which one you're talking
about i got about 20 of them maybe the
one that's next to uh
to grogu yeah then the next and one
that's like i've got a few other bigger
ones a bunch of diecast ones yeah
he's got a [ __ ] down over there some of
them are
great mazinger another one's like uh z
mazinger which was a
my friend made a lot of those he owns a
company that makes them called hl pro
it's a japanese company yeah he said and
then but if you talk about that one that
was a model i made that model
it's just blow molded plastic you gotta
cut it out of a damn
thing where it comes in a dam doesn't
even come in a box it came in a plastic
bag
and uh it's blow molded and you had to
cut it all out and paint it and glue it
all together
this one yeah so the big one well
there's two big ones or three bits
like i said they probably mean the one
that's next to baby yoda yes yes
because that's the one you can see
though it's the other one you can't
really see them as much
but yeah so you can see i'm like close
up yeah it's a model
yeah and it moves it just and it's got
dust on it right now
yeah it's a little dusty yeah it hasn't
moved in a while
he's just hanging out back there with
grogoo yeah
i never did glue the head on it oh it's
just on a little spike
because i wasn't sure if i wanted to
move to glue the head look it off into
another direction
or maybe i could get some kind of a ball
joint to install in there i didn't want
a fixed head
yeah i could see it yeah but yeah so on
the blu-ray
there's actually this really cool um
documentary that's like the making of
uh fire and ice and it's not fantastic
quality because they said that the only
uh copy of it that they had was ralph
bakshi's personal
copy of it that was like done on vhs
right
but we watched it and it was like
fascinating because it
went really in depth into the
rotoscoping
technique and how [ __ ]
labor-intensive this [ __ ] [ __ ] is
because they shot the entire movie
in live action in black and white
um they had all the people and they
showed that was just like this big sound
stage
with like climbing [ __ ] and everything
like that on it and they had it all
gritted up
like so they could select for later like
for the animators so they'll know like
where the backgrounds go and
you know everything is kind of blocked
out and whatnot
so they have the actors come in and they
had like the outfits
like similar to the outfits that you see
the animated ones like they you know
they have the same hair and the same
similar kind of
you know clothes and they had to do
all of this stuff so they shot the whole
movie and then
the animators came in and drew
over every single frame of the thing
they showed how they did it too yeah and
it was it was [ __ ] amazing and then
they had like the guys that were like
the background painters
and they said they had to do a thousand
paintings they had to do like two or
three paintings a day
like you know to keep up on the schedule
or whatever and you know what's
interesting is that a couple of the
people that worked on this movie like uh
went on to be super famous later
one of the dudes that was a background
painter on this is [ __ ] uh thomas
kincaid
painter of light they even had this dude
is so famous
that he even had like there's a chain of
mall stores
that sold his artwork you know what i
mean he did like landscapes and stuff
um and he had like books come out and
everything so that guy was
worked on this movie um the guy that
later created eon flux
uh worked on this movie um i think the
guy that did dinotopia
the those uh series of novels he worked
on it too
so there was just kind of all kind of
people that would go on to
be famous in this but once i like i knew
what rotoscoping was
but watching them doing it
and like realizing that they actually
had to shoot the film they had to make
the film essentially twice because they
had to film the whole thing
you know in live action first with the
people
and the costumes and everything and then
they had to have somebody paint all the
backgrounds
and then they had to have somebody
meticulously draw every single character
like over
every single frame everyone had to be
like the same color everyone had the
same
outfits everyone had to do and even
though it was like a whole team of
people working on it they all had to be
like standardized
yeah it's [ __ ] crazy yeah an hour's
worth of work only yielded like seven
seconds of of actual
uh film time yeah took my couple out i
think was did they say an hour
yeah because they had that one guy that
was bringing in each frame and he was
like
taking a picture of it taking a picture
of it and he said yeah this sequence
will take me an hour to shoot
and it's about i think it was about five
seconds or seven seconds or something
like that
they were working in teams you know what
i mean but a lot of stuff that they did
had to be thrown out it's just like
anything else a lot of it ends up on the
cutting room floor
because it has to be edited into
something that makes sense
it's a good little movie good movie it
could have been a little bit better
story wise
it did sag a bit in the middle i feel
like and well i it's not so much sagging
i just felt like it was a little bit
repetitive because
tiger kept getting kidnapped by the
subhumans and then she kept getting away
and then she kept getting kidnapped
again and then so they would
just kept fighting him there's not
really like a lot of dialogue in this
either it's much more like
chasing and fighting yeah and there was
a couple of places where
some things were kind of like a dead end
like
tigra gets i guess abducted by this big
uh
ogre type thing that takes takes her
back to a little hovel and there's a
damn witch in there
there's like this gorgeous woman who do
tries to kind of like put the moves on
her a little bit but then he
she takes a hair sample and turns out
she can find out your history through
this hair sample during this really like
magical dna
yeah she found out that that she was
wanted by necron which means that she
couldn't have
she couldn't do whatever she was gonna
do to her i think she's gonna do
something magical
to her or sacrifice her or something
and then end up she ends up getting
killed for it
and then she comes back as a skeleton to
and
asks for the hero to eventually
adventure there was something missing
there
it was like there should have been a
little bit more to her story
yeah i felt like that could have been
fleshed out a little bit because i liked
that character like i liked that big
ogre i liked that witch
yeah we didn't get much of her and i
liked the fact that she came back like
as a zombie essentially it was like
avenge me
and i was like that's cool we needed
more of that yeah we needed more of dark
wolf
and like what the hell his deal was
because he was like super cool well i
think there was some kind of back story
with that sorcerer and maybe necrons mom
but we think yeah i think that there was
but we didn't get it it does seem like
there was more stuff in this that could
that yeah
that got like left out right because one
of the other extras
on the um on the blu-ray was the guy
who played uh necron he didn't do his
voice
did he but he was he was the body yeah
and the face
he was the the body in the face and yeah
if you see pictures of him
he looked almost exactly like uh how he
was drawn
um and he was like uh he he did fencing
and stuff like that so
that's why they they got people that
were stunt men or dancers or whatever
you know obviously because movement was
really important and uh so they is so
they had like
it was interesting it wasn't really an
interview with him but they he had like
a diary that he had written
at the time that he was working on the
movie so it has him like
reading all the stuff and he so it was
his thing where he was saying that all
of the stuff that was left out about
dark wolf being necrons dad and there
being these whole other scenes
about you know whole other lines and
stuff that were left out
and they said too that the woman that
ended up playing juliana like in the
fight like the evil queen whatever like
in the final
uh movie they're like that wasn't the
first woman
that played her they said because the
first time they shot the live action it
was a different actress
um and then when they decided later on i
guess pretty late in the production
that either they couldn't get that woman
back for post-production stuff or they
decided they didn't like the way it was
working out
so they had to get a whole nother
actress in there
and they had to redraw like all of that
all of her [ __ ]
you know what i mean yeah monkey by
toenail says yes dark wolf necron his
mom seemed to
seem really sexually close well no dark
wolf was
necron's dad yeah yeah so i'm guessing
he was hitting juliana at some point
maybe which one the others the other the
the evil uh sorceress
the one with the red hair necrons mom no
that one no i don't that was just a
random woman
well you know that but i think there was
something there was some kind of
relationship between
that woman and necrons mom
had to be because she knew about necron
well the thing but yeah but everybody
knew about necron because he was like
the main bad guy but for some reason she
didn't want to like get in trouble for
keeping her i think there's there was
something missing
well yeah that's that's kind of the
thing about it is like i feel like
that was what that's one criticism
because like i said this movie is
gorgeous the rotoscoping is amazing like
the work that went into it is amazing
but the only criticism that i would give
it is that it should have focused more
on like story elements like that
like backstory more about dark wolf more
about that mysterious witch and the
troll in the woods
more about um you know necrons
relationship
more more with juliana and less of just
kind of running
away from subunits because i feel like a
lot of it was just running away from
something
they're living in a little bitty house
all right this troll and this
beautiful sorceress and she's dressed in
finery
what the hell's she doing in this little
bitty house you didn't notice that
yeah what is she doing out there so
there's a reason why she was out there
she'd been banished or something yeah
and that's the thing it's like
there's a lot of stuff that's kind of
just kind of leaves you wanting more
because you're like
what's the deal with that that should
have been like expanded out it's like
maybe they didn't want the movie to be
too long or whatever because it's pretty
short it's only like an hour and 20
something minutes
um but i do kind of feel like maybe this
they should have shifted the focus
less from like the chase scenes because
you know there was a lot of that there
was a lot of them running and fighting
uh you know subhumans and occasionally
dinosaurs
yeah um and then sometimes like you said
you get this cool thing like with the
witch and everything
and she was just in one scene and you're
just like well wait
what does she have to do with anybody
and why yeah and she's obviously
important the way she's dressed
yeah and she's out in the middle of
nowhere yeah
yeah so i wanted to know like what the
deal was and you know
and then there was the whole thing too
with like dark wolf because like i said
you go through half the movie thinking
like lauren
is like the hero because he's the only
survivor of
you know the the fire people or whatever
and then
you know dark wolf shows up and is
basically like steals that dude thunder
and he starts kicking ass well yeah
it was it was just the kind of situation
i think kind of like
luke and han solo yeah it was kind of
lauren was the
the young up-and-coming kind of guy all
right
he didn't really know how to be a hero
if you noticed
yeah i can there were a couple times
where he didn't seem
to seem interested in going back and
getting damn princess
teagrass he's like oh [ __ ] her yeah yeah
and dark wolf says you go back and get
her yeah
he's like all right all right so it was
actually i have to
yeah and then dark wolf he turns out it
is kind of a
you know he's old enough to be lauren's
dad
yeah okay he's in his early 50s or late
40s
so he's kind of being the the mentor
almost kind of like in the way
han solo was the mentor to luke yeah a
little bit older and more experienced
yeah right and uh and he's the one that
has the real
grudge it's a blood grudge it turns out
but they cut that out
yeah um he had a you know it's almost
kind of like king arthur and what's his
name mordred
his son mordred yeah remember he he had
to kill his own son
to purge that evil from the world so
they might have been taken from the
excalibur
yeah maybe that's what he was kind of
like a cross between king arthur
and uh batman yeah he's like a
prehistoric batman
yeah he kind of looks like that he looks
like back he's got that thing with the
little thing and
he's got a wolf mask on and just you see
his eyes are just green
sockets and they glow like like batman
yeah like batman just like batman and
he's got that damn batman voice
actually he sounds native it's like a
native american he's kind of like more
like uh
something you'd see from like you know
lakota nation or something
yeah it's like native american type
hollywood style
accent he's cool actually you know he's
the
he's the best character in the movie oh
yeah big time yeah well and the thing
about it too is that there's
another thing too with dark wolf is that
at one point lauren
and tigra are farting around in those
ruins and in those ruins
there's like a sculpture thing like a
rock thing on the wall that looks like
dark wolf's face with it
probably was that's what i mean so it's
like see i want to know what the [ __ ]
was up with that guy
did anybody write any fanfic that was
like expanding on this [ __ ] or do we
know
he was involved with the mom somehow the
mom went bad
well that's kind of what happened to um
king arthur except it was his
in excalibur it was his sister that
seduced him yeah through some kind of
magical thing where he made
she made herself look like his wife yeah
so you know and then
then uh so that might might have been to
take off on that maybe
necrons mom disguised herself
as dark wolves wife got pregnant buyer
and he had to go out there and [ __ ]
do a late term abortion
and very late term abortion i got to say
i kind of love necron's character too he
was totally totally over the top
uh and wacko but i thought that kind of
worked yeah i kept making jokes about
him the whole time because he's
he was like you know he's just kind of
like sitting on the throne the whole
time
like not the toilet he was sitting on
the actual throne and he's just kind of
just sitting there going like that
and i was just kind of like he's
wondering where he left his pants i
guess
thank you ken kenneth better set her fit
ken federer sent a 40 super chat like a
g
thank you very much dinner and a martini
on me thank you thank you very much been
a hell of a week for about a month now
missy and love you oh
we love you too man uh somebody like
somebody mentioned earlier that there's
actually a modern uh rotoscope movie
from japan
uh so i'll have to look that up because
i really really do like that animation
there are people still doing it um it's
just very very
time consuming obviously because like i
said you have to make the movie
essentially twice
dean says uh hey jenny what happened to
that fantastic red hair uh it's just a
wig
uh yeah that's it so the hairs of the
closet
oh i got one i have lots of different
colors oh he got one of his i got one
about it i'm gonna bust that [ __ ] out
when i'm ready
one of these days maybe maybe on the
wednesday sidetrack yeah
you can put it on it's a straight up
glendale oh my god it's so
so funny it's actually good for glenn
danzig
or um or ozzy osbourne
it's just black pretty much any or you
could be
yeah you could be any dude from like a
goth metal band or conan or something or
konya
well actually conan had bangs yeah uh
yeah coney and tara was kind of fluffier
and kind of brown right
it wasn't black well i mean in the movie
yeah drawing something and
in the drawings he had black yeah he
kind of had a prince valiant thing going
with his bangs it was kind of short
and yeah some of the comic books yeah
prince valiant or he
man yeah but then the other one i got
you guys are really gonna laugh
on that one man it's not here yet
i can't wait until that one arrives
that's my kpop [ __ ] weight i'm just
going to laugh my ass off and start like
oh boy
that's going to be that's a family
that's going to be so awesome it's
fluffy as [ __ ] that [ __ ] doesn't well
okay so when you wear that one
when you wear that one that's going to
be some special occasions yeah
why not yeah that'll definitely have to
be a special occasion [ __ ] and also
you need to wear i don't know if it um
will still go over your big
mess massive arms now or you have that
kind of gothy shirt that was kind of
like silky and
uh kind of shiny did you have the black
kind of shiny
yeah i got all kinds of stuff oh my god
i can't really fit that's what i was
gonna
say i thought my chance that arm's
expanded [ __ ] several inches many
inches
since i went that way back in the day
many many inches yeah
dean says uh did i read house of leaves
i did indeed
uh and actually i'm going to be at some
point this year
i've told myself i'm going to sit down
and commit to rereading that [ __ ]
and uh i'm going to do a do a book
review on it
but like i said that's one that that one
needs a long time to like digest because
that's like a super complicated
uh book and you really kind of have to
get immersed in it i loved it the first
time i read it
but i've been meaning to reread it i
just haven't had time to
but yeah um yeah tom small yes well
yeah stop prop says the movie is the
japanese one is called
on gaku r sound and it took them seven
years to make it
and it's also rotoscoped i've seen other
ones like that but like i said
i don't know like i said i knew how they
did it but i didn't realize how [ __ ]
god that would just take for i don't i
wouldn't have the patience to do that
kind of [ __ ] i know they do it in teams
but it's like in a way that seems kind
of harder because
it's hard to get consistency across
however many people are working on
working on the [ __ ]
i mean they all had to have you know the
color grading and then they showed the
one woman that was a pace she was
painted that sells you know she was on
the team that painted the cells
and she's like yeah we have all the you
know codes of what colors you're
supposed to use for everything
she's like but we're never entirely sure
how the director is going to want to
play this scene like what the lighting
is going to be like
so we have to do like three different
versions of every single one she's like
here's one where the lighting is more
sunlight and here's more where it's dark
and they're silhouetted and here's what
i'm like jesus [ __ ] christ how would
you keep track of all that [ __ ] yeah pat
watch it pat says man i should have
watched this before disgusting yeah go
ahead and watch
it's actually you can uh i think it's on
to be if you want to watch it for free
okay look here's the deal you guys know
i'm a big fan of conan one
i think that's that is the movie all
right
i love everything about that movie the
score
the philosophy behind it just
everything looking i think my favorite
movie really
right up there with that would be
predator one okay
and then after that maybe like alien
alien too but you guys know that's the
that's my ranking
all right i even got commando up there
and commandos
is is is the quintessential 80s action
shoot them up
i mean [ __ ] it watching commandos
like watching a video game a really good
video game
i'm gonna put conan at the very top fire
and ice is not as good as conan
but it's a conan like experience that i
want to see it a couple more times i
think give it a rest
it's the same kind of rotoscope artistry
that went on
in the uh in the animated version of uh
of uh what was the the lord of the rings
yeah well it's the same director same
director it feels a lot like lord of
rings which i want to see that one again
i haven't seen that in a long time i
want to see that hobbit he did i used to
love that when i was a kid
well the no the the one that uh ralph
bakshi did in the 70s
he did lord of the rings too but he also
did the hobbit like yeah he also
he did three of them though didn't he
they had the songs in it
yeah well he did the hobbit yeah and
then i think he just did lord of the
rings as
one movie one movie and then
lord of the rings well yeah i know that
it never ends yeah they don't do
yeah but it's because it you know it's
it's just one of those books
it's just one of the books yeah i
haven't seen him in a long time but the
thing is
is that the hobbit i didn't think was
done by the same it didn't the art
didn't look the same
well some of the animators might have
been different but it was the same
director okay
um but i remember you know what it's
like it's weird because i saw both of
those when i was growing up and for some
reason i liked the hobbit better
i even liked the hobbit book better than
lord of the rings i remember liking both
of those animated movies yeah they were
both good but i liked that and then
there was the third one came out and it
looked like the first one
same kind of art yeah it had songs in it
and everything and i remember
enjoying it also they showed it on
television
i want to get a ball i mean uh but
lord of the rings the animated one
looked looked
the most like reality it was rotoscoped
yeah don't you remember i haven't seen
that a long time yeah it looked really i
remember the hobbit better than the lord
of the rings okay the lord of the rings
was
looked better they had really cool uh
uh orcs you could tell that they were
just yeah they were they were cool orcs
in the
in the in uh hobbit too
soundprop says did he do watership down
i don't think that was ralph bakshi i
think that was um
i thought that was don bluth but i could
be wrong about that
that might it might be somebody else
entirely like don bluth was the same guy
that did like secretive nim and all that
kind of stuff
but it's like when we were watching uh
fire and ice last night i was like man
this made me want to
re-watch ralph bakshi's the hobbit and
it also made me want to watch
um rock and roll that canadian
uh animated movie from nelvana
kanabatsulon's in there yeah man go
ahead and
see see it you'll like it it's great
movie
it's good yeah it's you know it's fun
it's not
um it's not long it's not as good as
heavy metal no
and it's not as good as some of ralph
bakshi's other ones yeah but
just knowing the [ __ ]
the effort that it took to make this
[ __ ] which is just like mind-blowing
it's still good
it's still yeah and it's kind of you
know they're just trying to bring you
some frank frazetta-like
energy yeah and it works at that i think
the story could
i think the story originally was better
and they edited a lot of stuff out
i would like to have seen an extended
version of it with those elements still
in there and probably even better
yeah because that's kind of the
criticism that i would give is that it
needed more
expansion on some of the like really
fascinating parts of the story and less
of like the chasing and fighting
yeah i can tell stuff's missing yeah
yeah dj maniac says i think watership
down and the plague dogs were the same
studio yeah i'm pretty sure they were
um i really need to rewatch the plague
dogs too and i think that's also on to
be
ken says american pop that was another
ralph bakshi movie which i haven't i
think i saw that once when i was a kid
and i don't remember anything about it
uh pat's talking about rock and roll a
great movie with a great soundtrack i
agree
i saw it a zillion times when i was
growing up if you haven't seen it like i
said it's canadian and it's animated
and it's about a rock star thank you
scott thank you scott thank you for the
10
super chat man these are all high
rollers on here
and the answer of venom's question uh
yeah i like samurai movies uh
you used to see uh i've watched a bunch
of them i was really big into satuity
i've seen a lot of those other ichi
movies especially the old ones
um saw um some of the
kurosawas and um it's about it
yeah yeah they're good i also have uh
low wolf and cub i got the uh
criterion collection i think it's four
movies
very really six movies the six movies
yeah it's big
yeah the big seven i gotta go back and
see those again
long wolf and cub was the original uh
[ __ ] um mandalorian
mandalorian it just feels like it's a
wolf and cub
well yeah well you're not the only
person that said that yeah i'm pretty
sure people admitted that yeah well yeah
they said that's where the kind of they
got the idea from
yeah he's just like a you know an old
battle-hardened
warrior like having to carry a little
baby around baby in a baby car
baby in a baby cart yeah yeah uh alex
says i think rastan was based on fire
and ice not really i just love bringing
up rastan
yeah someone needs to get butt horked
yeah mandalorian is lone wolf and cub
essentially basically yeah
it is yeah it's the same thing um
[Laughter]
somebody asked me to review uh house of
the devil which i will get to eventually
i've seen that a couple times and i also
really love that movie so i will get to
that
uh too and uh you know so anything else
you would like to say about fire and ice
uh no that's it okay like i said we got
the blu-ray uh from esther so thank you
very much esther but if you want to
watch it i'm pretty sure it's on tv for
free
and it's probably on other streaming
yeah pat i've seen the carmen cut of uh
of lone wolf and cub what'd they call it
they called it oh yeah yeah yeah what
was the name of that shogun assassin
there you go yeah it's funny it's fun
too
it's just [ __ ] crazy looking crazy
yeah
i don't know if i've ever i'm sure i've
seen it yeah i've seen it it's just
i just don't remember an hour and a half
of insanity yeah
yeah you're like what the [ __ ] is this
movie about it it makes sense
but most of the story is cut out
just samurai fights and [ __ ] being
attacked by crazy ninja girls and
you know wait it's like who needs a
story you know why did you just have
like people fighting all the time oh
thank you stop prop
stop i have to drink today tomorrow is
my dry birthday
stop propaganda send a super chat twenty
dollars all these damn high rollers on
it i
can't understand what's going on oh my
goodness all this money coming out of
nowhere
kind of uh well it's not coming out of
nowhere you know it's coming from our
our lovely
fans kanavatsan says i've never seen the
deer hunter is it good yeah oh yeah
it's awesome yeah one of the really good
vietnam movies
yeah it's it's not up there with
apocalypse now but close
yeah it's different i remember i i
remember watching it it's like it'll
probably like bum you out big time
but it's i don't know it but it's really
really good
it's really really worthwhile yeah
mentioning that one makes you want to
see that other
um there was another real good
christopher walken war movie i haven't
seen in a long time
he plays a mercenary for hire was called
dogs of war
oh yeah yeah yeah he infiltrates inside
this african country
as a an ornithologist a guy studies
birds
yeah and he had that's his cover and he
goes in there and does a recon
gets [ __ ] captured thrown into prison
but he eventually gets out and goes back
in there and [ __ ] everybody up
by himself with but with some secret
[ __ ] grenade line rambo [ __ ] some
rambo [ __ ] yeah
pretty cool i haven't seen it forever
though
yeah uh somebody mentioned takashi
miyagi is great at making samurai movies
13 assassins is amazing i haven't seen
that but i've heard it's
going to be yeah um yeah and i wanted to
also say uh happy birthday up there to
to stop prop because he said it was it
was a birthday well he said it was his
dry birthday i'm assuming
so you know drink today why not i'm
probably gonna have a drink today i had
one drink last night while we were
watching fire and ice but
i might have another one tonight because
we got to watch a couple movies tonight
too
because we need one to talk about
tomorrow which i don't know what are we
gonna
talk about tomorrow i don't know i guess
we'll find out we got a bunch of stuff
yeah and then we're behind on
all right so we've been going for almost
50 minutes so i guess we can
shut it down for the day so thank you
everybody that came by thank you
everybody for your super chats that's
right generous super chats today i know
wow
that's i'm just you guys are welcome to
this you guys are welcome to the chat
room at any time
all right so have a good rest of your
weekend you guys and we will
see you again tomorrow bye